los hospitales de la región del gran
parís están al borde del colapso así lo
dicen médicos de hospitales que
advierten de que las unidades de
cuidados intensivos pronto estarán
desbordadas en la región de ildefons y
que en las próximas dos semanas el
personal tendrá que empezar a escoger
pacientes en un diario del domingo 41
especialistas advirtieron que los
doctores tendrán que empezar a escoger a
los pacientes para poder salvar la mayor
cantidad de vidas posible dijeron que
esto afectaría a todos los pacientes
aquellos que contrajeran kobe 19 y
aquellos hospitalizados por otras causas
uno de los que firmaron esta carta dijo
que los doctores se verán en una
situación imposible
y llegamos al punto en el que más de 50%
de los que son admitidos tienen menos de
50 años y estamos cerca de que eso pase
será extremadamente difícil elegir a
quien salvar entre los menores de 50 las
unidades de cuidado intensivo están
tratando a una media de 1.400 pacientes
al día durante este mes una cifra menor
a la registrada durante el repunte de la
primera ola en la
era pasada y eso pasó bajo un
confinamiento mucho más estricto con el
80 de los procedimientos quirúrgicos
pospuestos si si no hay más
restricciones para el 22 de abril
tendremos un 30% más de pacientes en
cuidados intensivos en comparación con
la primera ola para todos nunca a
laponia racc los médicos advierten de
que las medidas de confinamiento
aplicadas en parís y otras regiones no
serán suficientes para frenar los
contagios y que los hospitales pueden
tener que empezar a rechazar pacientes